1) Death
by
Golden Shower was Once Used as a Method of
Execution
Execution by golden shower was once used by
the Pathans (a.k.a. “Pashtuns”).
British soldier John Masters, who was stationed
in British India when he was 18 in 1933, described
this and other methods of execution for captured
soldiers in the region, “…if they [Pathans]
captured any soldiers… especially if the
soldiers were Sikhs or British, they would
usually castrate and behead them.
Both these operations were frequently done
by the women.
Sometimes they would torture prisoners with
the death of a thousand cuts, pushing grass
and thorns into each wound as it was made.
Sometimes they would peg the prisoner out
and, with a stick, force his jaws so wide
open that he could not swallow, and then the
women would urinate in his open mouth (taking
turns) till he drowned.”
2) 7-Up Originally Contained Psychiatric Medication
The lemon-lime flavored soda, 7-UP, was created
by Charles Grigg of the Howdy Corporation
in 1929, originally named "Bib-Label Lithiated
Lemon-Lime Soda", and included lithium citrate
in its formula.
This is a mood-stabilizing drug that was popular
in the late 19th and early 20th centuries,
and is still occasionally used today for people
with conditions like bipolar disorder.
Surprisingly, lithium citrate stuck around
in 7-UP all the way until 1950, when research
showed it had potentially dangerous side effects.
3) Playdoh was Originally Wallpaper Cleaner
In 1933, a young Cleo McVicker was at a meeting
with Kroger grocery store executives when
they asked if his company, Kutol, made wallpaper
cleaner.
With Kutol desperately needing money, Cleo
told them they did- a bold lie.
Kroger subsequently ordered 15,000 cases of
the product with a $5,000 penalty if Kutol
didn’t deliver on time.
Kutol then copied a commonly used wallpaper
cleaner recipe and the compound that ultimately
would become Play-Doh was born.As coal heat
began to go the way of the dodo and vinyl
wallpaper was invented, few needed wallpaper
cleaner anymore and the McVicker’s product
was virtually obsolete.
That’s when Kay Zufall, the sister-in-law
of one of the executives at Kutol came up
with the idea of using the substance as a
toy modeling compound.
The result was that Kutol removed the detergent
from the dough and added an almond scent and
some coloring.
They re-christen the compound: “Kutol’s
Rainbow Modeling Compound”, which was soon
changed to “Play-Doh” at the suggestion
of Kay.
With a little help from Bob Keeshan, better
known as Captain Kangaroo, who was promised
2% of the sales generated if he promoted it
on his show, Play-Doh quickly became a national
hit.
4) Bubble Wrap was Originally Wallpaper
Bubble Wrap was invented by two engineers
Al Fielding and Marc Chavannes in Hawthorne,
N.J. in 1957.
The two were not, however, trying to make
a product to be used as packaging material.
Rather, they were trying to create a textured
wallpaper.
When this use of the product didn’t pan
out, they decided to market it as greenhouse
insulation.
This idea didn’t sell well either.Then,
on October the 5, 1959, IBM announced their
new 1401 variable word length computer and
a lightbulb went off- Bubble Wrap could be
used as a good packaging material to protect
the computer while it was being shipped.
The pair pitched the idea to IBM, who loved
it.
And the rest, as they say, is history.
5) Einstein Got His Wife to Agree to a Divorce
Him by Promising His Nobel Prize Funds to
Her if He Ever Won One
In 1919, Einstein was looking to finally divorce
his wife who had thus far resisted the idea,
despite that they had long been separated.
To convince her, he wrote her a letter stating,
“Dear Mileva,
The endeavor finally to put my private affairs
in some state of order prompts me to suggest
the divorce to you for the second time...
I would grant you significant pecuniary advantages
through particularly generous concessions.
9,000 M instead of 6,000 M, with the provision
that 2,000 of it be deposited annually for
the benefit of the children.
The Nobel Prize — in the event of the divorce
and in the event that it is bestowed upon
me — would be ceded to you in full…
The widow’s pension would be promised to
you in the case of a divorce.
Naturally, I would make such huge sacrifices
only in the case of a voluntary divorce.
If you do not consent to the divorce, from
now on, not a cent about 6,000 M per year
will be sent to Switzerland…”
Despite that he’d not yet won a Nobel Prize
for her to collect the large cash prize, after
thinking it over for a week, she accepted.
6) There Once was a Man Who ate an Entire
Airplane
The eating disorder known as pica is characterized
by persistent and compulsive cravings to eat
nonfood items.
Some people have turned their appetite for
these non-digestable foods into a career.
Perhaps one of the most notable individuals
on this front is MICHEL LOTITO, aka Monsieu
Mangetout- "Mister Eats All", who specialized
in eating metal.
If that doesn’t sound too impressive, perhaps
we should mention that from 1959 to 1997,
Michel consumed nearly nine tons of metal,
including 18 bicycles, 15 shopping carts,
7 television sets, 6 chandeliers, 2 bed frames,
an entire Cessna airplane (which took him
about two years), 1 coffin, and 400m of a
steel chain.
7) Sleeping Beauty is Based on a Story of
a King Who Raped a Sleeping Girl
The story is called The Sun, the Moon, and
Talia, written, or at the least collected
and composed, by the Italian poet Giambattista
Basile in 1634.
The story goes that on a hunting trip, a king
stumbles on an estate in the woods where he
finds a beautiful young woman that he can’t
wake up.
So , to quote, “...being on fire with love,
he carried her to a couch and, having gathered
the fruits of love, left her lying there.
Then he returned to his own kingdom and for
a long time entirely forgot the affair.”Ultimately
the sleeping girl, cared for by fairies, gave
birth to twins, then later woke up.
It’s at this point the king remembered the
girl and decided to go back to the house to
see her again...
This time, though, he found her awake.
After the king explained to her how she’d
gotten pregnant, naturally she fell in love
with him…
(He was, no doubt, dreamy) and he decided
he loved her too.
The only problem- he was already married.
When the queen found out about the affair,
she attempts to have the babies fed to the
king unknowingly and then tries to kill Talia.
Instead the chef hides the kids and the King
kills his wife and marries his raped mistress,
and they live happily ever after, with the
last line of the story being (translated):
“Lucky people, so ’tis said, Are blessed
by Fortune whilst in bed.”
8) There Once was a Girl Who Had No Vagina
but Got Stabbed and Had a Baby
Published in the British Journal of Obstetrics
and Gynaecology, in 1988, there is a rather
curious paper entitled: Oral conception.
Impregnation via the proximal gastrointestinal
tract in a patient with an aplastic distal
vagina.
Case report.
In it, the doctors describes a 15-year-old
girl in the small African country of Lesotho
who arrived at a local hospital with all the
signs of a woman in labor.
Upon examination, the doctors found no vagina,
only a shallow skin dimple.
After a successful C-section resulted in a
healthy baby boy, the doctors noted:
“While closing the abdominal wall, curiosity
could not be contained any longer and the
patient was interviewed with the help of a
sympathetic nursing sister…
The patient was well aware of the fact that
she had no vagina and she had started oral
experiments after disappointing attempts at
conventional intercourse.
Just before she was stabbed in the abdomen
[some 278 days previous to giving birth] she
had practiced fellatio with her new boyfriend
and was caught in the act by her former lover.
The fight with knives ensued.”
The physicians later learned that while performing
surgery to repair the stab wounds, the surgeons
had found two holes that opened the girl's
stomach to her abdominal cavity.
Thus, it is theorized by the later doctors
in the report that the sperm in the girl's
stomach gained access to her reproductive
organs through her injured gastrointestinal
tract shortly after she ingested it.
Interestingly, getting pregnant as the result
of sperm originating in a woman’s abdomen
is possible enough that in the 1980s, during
the early days of fertility treatments, doctors
sometimes performed a procedure called DIPI
(direct intraperitoneal insemination) during
which they injected sperm into the lower abdomen
hoping that it would find its way to an egg,
similar to what happened in the case report,
except obviously not going through the stomach.
9) There Once was a Guy Who Survived Two Nuclear
Explosions
At the age of 29, Tsutomu Yamaguchi was on
his way back home from a three month long
business trip to Hiroshima on August 6, 1945.
On his way to the train station, he saw a
bomber flying over the city and "two small
parachutes", then a rush of blinding light,
sound, wind, and heat knocked him to the ground.
Mr. Yamaguchi had the misfortune of being
approximately 3 km from a nuclear blast.
The immediate effects of this were his ear
drums rupturing, temporarily blindness, and
burns over much of his upper body.
Three days later he found himself back at
home in Nagasaki, and even reported for work…
According to Yamaguchi, while discussing with
his boss how he got the burns, the air-raid
sirens went off and then, once again, he saw
a blinding white light…
Surprisingly, unlike so many others, the only
major permanent physical health problem’s
Yamaguchi had as the result of the bombings
and exposure to large amounts of ionizing
radiation was the loss of hearing in his left
ear.
He lived to the ripe old age of 93, dying
of stomach cancer on January 4, 2010.
10) The Founder of Fedex once Gambled the
Company’s Last Funds in Las Vegas to Save
It
The man is Frederick W. Smith who founded
FedEx in 1971.
The company struggled in its early days and
at its low point, all they had was about $5000
left in the bank.
Desperate, Smith made a final pitch for more
funding, but was refused, leaving FedEx more
or less dead on the ground when they’d not
be able to fuel their planes the following
Monday.Instead of accepting defeat, Smith
flew to Las Vegas for the weekend and played
Black Jack with the remaining company funds.
Thanks to this, by Monday FedEx had $32,000
in its bank account, which was just enough
to cover the fuel for their planes and to
continue operating a few days more.
When asked what he’d been thinking taking
a chance like that with company funds, he
stated: “What difference does it make?
Without the funds for the fuel companies,
we couldn’t have flown anyway.”It turns
out, a few days more was all he needed.
Shortly thereafter, Smith successfully managed
to raise $11 million to keep the company afloat
and, by 1976, Federal Express made its first
profit of $3.6 million.
Today the company employs over 300,000 people
and has annual revenues of about $47 billion.
11) Daylight Saving Time Once Thwarted a Terrorist
Attack
In September of 1999, the West Bank was on
daylight saving time while Israel was on standard
time; West Bank terrorists prepared bombs
set on timers and smuggled them to their associates
in Israel.
As a result, the bombs exploded one hour sooner
than the terrorists in Israel thought they
would.
Thus, the three terrorists died instead of
the two busloads of people who were the intended
targets.
12) The Can Opener wasn’t Invented for Decades
After the Can
In 1810, Nicholas Appert won a prize offered
by Napoleon Bonaparte for his method of keeping
food fresh by sterilization.
Although he didn’t understand exactly why
it worked, Appert found that food stayed fresh
for long periods of time if you could seal
it tightly in a container, in his case a glass
jar, and then heat it up.
Later that year an inventor, Peter Durand,
received a patent for the world’s first
can made of iron and tin.
Combined with Appert’s sterilization method,
long term canned food preservation became
possible.
Unfortunately, there was no can opener forthcoming
owing to how thick the can and lids were.
The age old “smash it with a hammer and
knife” technique was the common opening
method.
Ultimately a method for making thinner cans
was created, resulting in various can openers
being invented, the first patented in 1858,
nearly a half century after the can was invented.
13) The Guy Who Invented the Fender Guitar
Never Learned to Play Guitar
Leo Fender, inventor of one of the most popular
electric guitar brands in the world, was an
accountant before losing his job in the Great
Depression.
When this happened, he decided to turn his
hobby of tinkering with electronics into a
business- “Fender Radio and Record Shop”
where he ultimately invented various amplifiers
and later guitars.
Despite designing the first commercially successful
solid-body electric guitar, the Telecaster,
and the most influential of all electric guitars,
the Stratocaster, and inventing the solid-body
electric bass guitar, the Precision bass,
Leo Fender never learned to play guitar.
14) Piccasso’s Full Name Can’t Be Posted
on Twitter
Pablo Picasso’s full name was Pablo Diego
José Francisco de Paula Juan Nepomuceno María
de los Remedios Cipriano de la Santísima
Trinidad Ruiz y Picasso.
15) High Heels Were Once the Height of Men’s
Fashion
The first high heel wearers are believed to
have been Persian horseback warriors sometime
around the ninth century.
The extended heel is thought to have been
developed specifically for riding, to keep
the rider’s foot from slipping out of the
stirrups.
After a group of Persian diplomats visited
Europe in the late 16th century, Persian-style
high heeled shoes were adopted by Western
European aristocrats.
The shoes became a status symbol, with ornate
designs and ultra-high heels coming into fashion,
such as the case of King Louis XIV sporting
four inch heels, often decorated with elaborate
battle scenes.
Not to be outdone, women of the 1600s started
copying the fashion.
Around the same time, lower class citizens
also started wearing high heels, resulting
in the elite making their heels increasingly
higher.
They also began to differentiate heels into
two kinds- fat heels for men and skinny for
women.
By the 18th century, high heels disappeared
almost completely from men’s fashion outside
of cowboy boots, and not long after women
mostly stopped wearing them too.
However, the heel came back into fashion for
women in the mid-19th century with the advent
of photography.
Why?
Pornographers began dressing models for risqué
post cards and other photographs in little
else but high heels.
16) Green Eggs and Ham was the Product of
a Bet
Dr. Seuss, a.k.a. Theodore Geisel, wrote “Green
Eggs and Ham” on a bet that he couldn’t
write a book with 50 or fewer distinct words.
The bet was made in 1960 with Bennett Cerf,
the co-founder of Random House, and was for
$50 (about $404 today).
Green Eggs and Ham went on to become the fourth
best-selling English children’s book in
history.
17) Al Capone’s Brother was a Prohibition
Officer
Al Capone’s brother, James Vincenzo Capone,
left the family at the age of 16 to join the
circus in 1908, traveling throughout the Midwest
going by the name “Richard Hart”, in order
to mask his Italian heritage.
He ultimately settled in Homer, Nebraska,
where he became Homer’s town marshal and
later a state sheriff.
It was then that he chose to seek out more
excitement by becoming a prohibition enforcement
officer, something he was extremely effective
at, though known to be overly brutal in handling
bootleggers.
Around this same time, his brother Al, was
rising in fame as a gangster in Chicago, particularly
known for, of course, bootlegging.
18) There Once was a Siberian Family Who Didn’t
Encounter Other Humans for Over 40 Years
Karp Lykov was a member of a long persecuted
fundamentalist Russian Orthodox sect known
as the Old Believers.
In 1936, while working the fields with his
brother near their village, a Communist guard
came by and shot his brother right in front
of him.
Karp immediately grabbed his family (which,
at the time, only consisted of his wife, Akulina
, his son Savin, and his 2-year old daughter
Natalia) and disappeared into the Siberian
wilderness.
It would be another 42 years before the family
would encounter other humans again- a team
of geologists spotted their hut when flying
over in a helicopter.Karp and his wife (who
would die of starvation in 1961 thanks to
a cold snap that killed all their crops the
summer before), had two more children in the
wild, Dmitry and Agafia.
For reference, Agafia was 35 when she first
saw humans outside of her family.
None of the family knew anything of the outside
world from 1936 to 1978.
By 1988, Agafia was the only surviving member
of the family.
She remained at her remote home until January
of 2016 when she had to be airlifted to a
hospital due to severe pain in her leg.
After healing up, however, she returned to
the harsh Siberian wilderness.
19) There is an ATM in Antarctica
There is an ATM at McMurdo Station in Antarctica,
about 840 miles or 1351 km from the South
Pole.
Not surprisingly, this ATM is the most southern
ATM in the world.
The most northern ATM in the world is in Longyearbyen,
Svalbard, Norway, which is about half way
between mainland Norway and the North Pole.
The world’s highest ATM is at Khanjerab
Pass 15,397 ft (4.7 km) above sea level.
Finally, the world’s lowest ATM is in Ein
Bokek, near the Dead Sea in a grocery store
that is 1381 ft. (420 m) below sea level.
20) The First Woman to Cast a Vote in Chicago
Did so with Her Feet
The woman was Kittie Smith.
Smith lost her arms as a child, after having
both her arms and hands burned badly on a
kitchen stove.
As an adult, Kittie eventually became the
first woman to vote in Chicago Illinois in
1913.
”Hold on there!”
You say?
“The 19th Amendment wasn’t passed until
1920.
How was she able to vote in 1913?”
In Illinois, on June 26, 1913, women began
being allowed to vote on presidential and
many other elections.
Shortly after, an estimated 250,000 women,
with Kittie Smith’s feet leading the way,
voted in Chicago Illinois when the first Illinois
election took place after that bill passed.
21) Charles Osborne had the Hiccups for 68
Straight Years
In 1922, Charles Osborne was weighing a hog
for slaughter when he had a little accident.
As he stated, “I was hanging a 350 pound
hog for butchering.
I picked it up and then I fell down.
I felt nothing, but the doctor said later
that I busted a blood vessel the size of a
pin in my brain.”
Directly after the fall, Osborne began hiccupping
at a rate of around 40 times per minute on
average.
Throughout his life, this gradually slowed
to about 20 hiccups per minute until his hiccups
finally stopped mysteriously about one year
before his death in 1991.This approximate
68 year stretch of hiccups from 1922 to 1990
is considered a world record for continuous
hiccups.
22) KFC is the Traditional Christmas Dinner
in Japan
In 1974, KFC started a huge advertising campaign
in Japan called “Kurisumasu ni wa kentakkii!”
(Kentucky for Christmas!), with the idea being
that in a land bereft of the customary turkey
for celebratory dinner, fried chicken was
the next best thing.
This campaign was ludicrously popular in part
thanks to the popularity of American culture
in Japan at the time.
Today, the custom of eating KFC for Christmas
is so popular in Japan that you’ll not only
see lines of people snaked outside every branch
in the country, but people even reserve their
buckets of weeks, and sometimes months, in
advance just to see it on their dinner tables
on Christmas!
23) In 1899, 90% of All Taxis in New York
City were Electric Cars
In 1842, two inventors, American, Thomas Davenport,
and a Scotsman, Robert Davidson, separately
created the first practical electric cars
with rechargeable batteries.
By 1899, the technology had improved such
that 90% of all taxis in New York City were
electric cars.
Not only that, but in 1899 and 1900, electric
cars outsold all other types of cars, such
as gas and steam powered vehicles.
Ultimately Henry Ford and the rise of highways
killed the electric car industry.
Nonetheless, Ford’s wife, Clara, preferred
the 1914 Detroit Electric car, which had a
range of 80 miles, over her husband’s cars.
24) There Once was a Man who was a Dwarf and
Later a Giant
Adam Rainer of Graz, Austria reached a height
of just 4 feet 6.3 inches (1.38 m) by the
age of 18.
For reference, the cutoff for someone being
classified as a dwarf is usually considered
to be an adult height of less than 4 feet
10 inches (1.47 m).
According to Rainier, by the time he hit 21,
while still barely classified as a dwarf in
height, his shoe size had shot up to a European
size 53, which would be about a size 20 in
the U.S. (for reference, Shaquille O’Neal
wears a size US size 22-23).Then his body
followed- from his 21st birthday to his 32nd,
Rainer went from just under 4 feet 10 inches
tall to 7 feet 2 inches (1.47 m to 2.18 m).
As to what caused his bizarre growth spurt
as an adult, doctors F. Windholz and A. Mandl
discovered a tumor on his pituitary gland,
which resulted in a condition known as acromegaly,
where the pituitary gland produces excessive
amounts of growth hormone during adulthood.
To try to fix the problem, in 1930 doctors
removed the tumor, but he still continued
to grow, albeit at a much slower rate.
He died at the age of 51 in 1950 at a height
of about 7 feet 8 inches (2.34 m), making
him the only known person to spend time as
an adult officially classified as a dwarf
and then as a giant.
25) The Inventor of the Pringles can was Buried
in One
Upon his death in 2008, just 20 days shy of
his 90th birthday, the inventor of the Pringles
can, Fredric J. Baur, was cremated.
In keeping with his wishes, his family filled
a Pringles can with as much of his ashes as
fit and buried it.
As to what flavor, his son, Larry, stated,
“My siblings and I briefly debated what
flavor to use, but I said, ‘Look, we need
to use the original.’”